ou l'aise
le chef aux mains nues ils ne dirigent
pas il sculpte la musique pour
interpréter les oeuvres contemporaines
et les siennes en particulier il a
inventé un vocabulaire une grammaire du
geste
trois jeunes chefs triés sur le volet
australiens allemands écossais ont la
chance de suivre la classe du maître
tous les jours de 10h à 12h il travaille
dans une salle de la cité du livre
ils ont à leur disposition le magnifique
ensemble intercontemporain créé par
boulez augmenté de quelques étudiants de
haut vol
ils connaissent très bien la partition
ils ont été très bien préparé mais
évidemment ils n'ont jamais dirigé cette
heure est donc ça leur pose des
problèmes comme vous avez pu voir ça
leur pose des problèmes qui sont
différents de ce qu'ils ont appris
qu'ils sont autres mais s'ils n'étaient
pas des jeunes professionnels il aurait
jamais pu maîtriser même ce qu'il m'est
très simplement la partition d'éclat
multiples composés par boulez est
particulièrement ardue et l'on peut
s'étonner que de 12h à 13h chaque jour
le public vienne assister en nombre à la
place du maître quelques mots
d'explication et la répétition commence
les spectateurs souvent très initiés ont
une qualité de regarder d'écouter
exceptionnel certains suivent l'oeuvre
sur la partition pour la plupart d'entre
eux c'est un enchantement dont il
n'hésite pas à nous par les magiciens
ont fait un jour il a dit de la musique
cette flamme
imaginez quatre cas ce que vous venez de
vous assister dans la notion de boulez
d'être l'ouverture c'est magique pour
vous blesse c'est très grand ses très
grands mais ça veut dire quoi cette
région c'est très grand parce que c'est
un compositeur extraordinaire c'est
aussi un chef d'orchestre dire que le
voir travailler ça aide pas toujours à
lire sa musique monde n'est pas capable
de le faire mais à l'entendre en tout
cas il a il à ce souci je dirais de
l'explication tout simplement par le
geste parfois par la voix de boulez que
christie par exemple pour le baroque
c'est là que j'ai travaillé avec pierre
boulez et je suis en tout cas très très
fasciné par la musique contemporaine
je trouve que entendre des oeuvres de ce
temps des oeuvres en train de se faire
aussi c'est quand même une aventure
formidable mais j'aime beaucoup aussi ce
que fait william christie je tiens le
compter dans ce lieu au début de cette
édition spéciale 11000 festival de dix
stations 14 millions de français qui
vont les pendant l'été un petit peu
partout qu'elle doit être selon vous
ministre la place de l'état dans toutes
ses manifestations culturelles et des
aidés par l'argent de laisser les
initiatives comme enquêteur ne dis
souvent on cherche souvent qu'elle vient
pas au lecteur
le festival c'est une manifestation
ponctuelle temporaire l'état et est très
présent dans l'ensemble des institutions
culturelles il aide les équipes
permanentes
il aide à la création il aide aussi à la
rencontre avec les publics
les festivals sont des moments quand
même très très particulier c'est un
moment un moment fort où beaucoup de
gens des publics de toutes sortes se
réunissent
donc l'état doit l'a accompagné je
dirais laisser fleurir vous lisez vous
même le nombre des festivals est
étonnant c'est bien maintenant les
régions tous à renouveler le public faut
trouver des jeunes pour les zones et
notamment à l'art lyrique
donc c'est un travail qu'on doit faire
des lincoln avec de la formation
ça c'est vrai pour tous qu'ils aient
accès à la création ça n'est pas propre
au festival mais les festivals offre je
crois une occasion de rencontres avec
des publics y compris avec les publics
de nouveaux peut-être plus facile
d'abord parce que souvent c'est sous un
ciel magnifique dans des belleville ou
des très beaux monuments les festivals
viennent souvent se nicher dans un
monument alors ya déjà le plaisir de la
découverte du du lieu on vous a vu tout
à l'heure au domaine saint jean c'est un
endroit magnifique
et puis le festival c'est souvent ça
correspond à un moment de grande liberté
des publics peut-être sont-ils plus
disponibles plus accueilli rentrée est
ce qu'il y a notamment pour leur dire
est qu est-ce qu il ya une vraie
démocratisation parce que c'est cher
souvent c'est cher mais je pense qu'il
ya des choses qui sont tout à fait en
mouvement pour l'art lyrique comme dans
d'autres disciplines
d'abord parce que le champ est quand
même une des formes d'expression à la
fois les plus accessibles
et puis les plus les plus
extraordinaires parce que c'est quand
même le plus bel instrument la voix
c'est c'est le corps donc je crois qu'il
ya un très grand appétit pour l'art
lyrique
c'est vrai qu'il y à des publics qui
pendant longtemps se sont appropriés cet
art là mais on le voit ici avec ce avec
ses répétitions publiques avec six
concerts les gens les gens y viennent
plus facilement c'est vrai que dans les
lieux consacrés j'en reviens à votre
rôle en tant qu'etat vous devez
saupoudré beaucoup de manifestations
beaucoup de subventions ou est-ce que
votre choix sera effectivement de de
rationaliser d'insister dans un secteur
plutôt dans un autre je crois que l'état
d'abord il faut il faut bien le
le constater et s'en réjouir ce n'est
pas l'état qui saupoudre les festivals
les festivals fleurissent sont des
initiatives prises parfois au plan local
sur la répartition de son aide
je crois que l'état doit à la fois être
présent dans des lieux très différents
effectivement mais c'est vrai aussi qu'à
saupoudrage trop grand ne permet pas d
hier d aventure artistique de ceux de se
construire donc il faut être attentif à
ce qui apparaît ce qui est nouveau il
faut aussi accompagner des actions qui
ont trouvé leurs rapports avec une
région et qui ont leurs qui ont leur vie
propre vous savez l'état ne fait pas
tout dans le domaine de l'art et de la
culture
alors est ce que vous êtes aussi un peu
hip hop
si je vous dis le thrash metal trance
goa farid berki est ce que vous
connaissez le vent contexte et non la
manche et là dessus personnellement non
non non et je la vole entre à chelsea
c'est du hard rock ultra violent rythme
saturer son garage mais tout à fait il
ya des publics en tout cas qu'ils
adorent ça je crois que forte
heureusement ce n'est pas le goût du
ministre qu'ils commandent la vie
artistement et en plus je suis quand
même entouré par des gens plus jeunes
que moi qui me le haut des pratiques
heureusement différentes des miennes
qu'ils allaient passer il ya peu de
temps
vingt-quatre heures à bourges et c'était
vraiment le printemps euros j'ai trouvé
ça tout à fait magnifique
alors je profite de la présence vous
pose évidemment la question d'actualité
sur la censure qu'est ce qu'on doit san
siro gb jusqu'au venturer rien rien
serez jamais rien je crois que les actes
de censure n'ont pas de sens même si on
sait l'effet les violences quand on voit
le nombre de multiplication de viols
d'agressions sexuelles de problèmes de
pédophilie
est-ce qu'il faut pas avoir des nous ne
sommes pas là je vois que vous nous
parler du film est de baise-moi ce n'est
pas d'un acte de censure c'est
l'application de la loi
ça n'est pas l'état ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui décide tel film peut ou
ne peut pas être vu nous avons des
textes nous avons une obligation de
protection des mineurs et fort
heureusement l'application de cette
obligation a confié à une commission qui
est une commission indépendante en
l'occurrence elle avait jugé je croit
raisonnablement que l'interdiction aux
moins de 16 ans pouvait suffire avec un
avertissement mais nos concitoyens ont
le droit de saisir le juge
certains lancés avec je crois d'ailleurs
face aux dépenses et qui n'ont pas grand
chose à voir avec ni avec la création
artistique ni réellement avec la
protection des mineurs mais ils ont
engagé un contentieux la chose jugée que
le visa a disparu je le regrette je le
regrette parce que personnellement je
pense que il eût mieux valu laisser ce
film se défendre par lui même plutôt que
de l'auréolé vont de réforme ou
s'effondrer plutôt que de l'auréolé
comme ça de d'un statut de 2,2
martyr je le répète ceux qui ont
actionné la justice en l'occurrence ne
sont pas à mes yeux les meilleurs juges
de tout cela c'est un filon qui a une
réelle violence d'ailleurs la commission
l'avait quand ce traité personnellement
je préfère toujours qu'on laisse au
maximum les gens se faire leur propre
point de vue mais la loi je le répète en
l'occurrence la loi protège les mineurs
suivants un certain nombre de critères
et dans notre pays nous sommes encore
mineur jusqu'à 18 ans est le seul moyen
d'interdire aujourd'hui un film on voit
le 18 ans c'est malheureusement de le
qualifier films x j'aurais souhaité que
le film vivre sa vie naturellement et
chacun se serait fait un aveu vacances
merci beaucoup catherine tasca voilà je
voudrais remercier toute l'équipe qui a
préparé cette édition spéciale du
journal béatrice car il ya michel
mompontet michel trudeau vie cia
georges-bayrou ya beaucoup de gens ici
qui ont travaillé pour cette édition
spéciale qui s'est passé sous un ciel
serein avec une ouverture du festival
d'art lyrique ce soir à aix en provence